Guten Morgen Lino.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Daten Verkehrskontrolle sie haben zu viele Daten versendet das macht dann 20 € wohin darf ich Ihnen das überweisen.
Auf mein Paypal Konto haben.
Aux
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 285 vom 4. Februar 2019 habe ich 2018 gesagt oder wie.
Ja kann ja sein jedes Jahr die gleichen Nachrichten bei uns kommt man mal ein bisschen durcheinander.
Stuten weißt du was häufig als Feedback kommt und nicht immer verstehen die Leute den Witz am Anfang ne diesmal diesmal ich auch nicht.
Ich habe die noch nicht verstanden warum hat er jetzt witzig.
Ja ich wollte jetzt Daten Verkehrskontrolle machen da muss ich dir 20 € Monat überweisen.
Das stimmt natürlich.
Da komme gleich drauf.
Kommen wir gleich drauf stimmt ich habe tatsächlich kurz gebraucht.
Keine Ursache wenn ich mal ein Witz.
Datum aber gesagt, können wir zum.
Sendung Sendungsnummer auch gesagt genau nachher das.
Feedback von Martin,
für eine und zwar geht es um die Voting Moratorium in der Schweiz für Wanja ich war ein bisschen unsicher wie das da jetzt genau ist ob das jetzt eröffnet ist oder nicht deswegen wurde das hier einmal genaustens erklärt.
Und das ist auch wichtig für eine eidgenössische Volksinitiative müssen in der Schweiz mindestens 100.000 gültige Unterschriften in 18 Monaten gesammelt werden das klingt,
erst einmal nicht mehr viel ist aber anspruchsvoll und viele scheitern bereits daran auch muss jede Unterschrift bei der Gemeinde wo die unterschreibende Person wohnt beglaubigt werden was zu einem erheblichen bürokratisch,
auf entführt um die 100000 gültige Unterschrift zu erreichen benötigt man aufgrund von Fehlern doppelten Unterschriften und so weiter wohl eher,
110000 Unterschrift und mehr ja das ist schlecht bei 100000 aufzuhören wenn der am Ende einer als unglücklich gezählt wird,
dann hast du es nicht erreichen.
Minister ernst.
Wenn die Volksinitiative zustande kommt weil genügend Unterschriften gesammelt werden wird früher oder später darüber abgestimmt früher oder später weil es zuerst das Parlament damit befasst und man keinen Anspruch auf eine schnelle Volksabstimmung hat,
in der Volksabstimmung ist die Hürde hoch,
weil nicht nur eine Mehrheit der Stimmen erforderlich ist sondern die Volksinitiative auch in einer Mehrheit der Kantone angenommen werden,
Harry momentan werden noch keine Unterschriften gesammelt,
das ist der wichtige Punkt sondern Unterstützer gesucht dafür wird die Plattform wecollect verwendet die wir ja auch verlinkt halten und jetzt auch,
hier noch einmal in den Kommentar ist da kann man nämlich jetzt quasi unterschriftenbögen als PDF runterladen ausdrucken dann unterzeichnen lassen und dann per Briefpost an das Initiativkomitee senden das heißt im Moment werden dort,
noch Leute gesucht die sich quasi bereit erklären,
fünf oder mehr ist natürlich die Hoffnung Unterschriften zu sammeln und davon suchen 17000 dann hätten sie also
10000 Leute die fünf oder mehr Unterschriften versprochen haben sagen wir mal da damit kommst du auf 50 dann bleibt immer noch die andere Hälfte der Last bei denen oder bei denen den Leuten die dann mehr machen und dann haben sie,
also ich denke eigentlich dass das kann man kriegt man zu schaffen.
Die Anzeige kriegt man ja in 18 Monaten wahrscheinlich hin mit ein paar koordinierten.
Belästigung der Leute also zieht man sich irgendwie eine Weste an und quatsche Leute an am Alexanderplatz oder wieder in der Schweiz heißt und,
der kriegt das in 18 Monaten schon hin das ist aber auf jeden Fall viel Arbeit.
Und war das was mir dann natürlich hier so ein bisschen Sorgen macht ist oder was was die Arbeit glaube ich sehr stark erhöht,
dass das dass du das den Leuten immer wieder erklären muss warum man jetzt dagegen sein soll warum das überhaupt ne dass viele Leute auf Anhieb verstehen ja bei dem Thema E-Voting,
nicht unbedingt warum soll ich da jetzt gegen sein warum du warum soll ich das überhaupt kümmern ja wenn du dich jetzt eh wieder hin stellst und sagst die wir hier gegen das robbensterben ja oder gegen den Klimawandel oder oder gegen gegen,
Terroristen oder gegen Ausländer ne das könntest du zwar recht da kriegst du schnell den Leuten nicht erklären die wissen sofort bin ich für oder gegen,
und.
Musst halt einfach Musik klar argumentieren sein ist wie Ausländer nur schlimmer.
Wie Ausländer nur elektronisch.
Jetzt beginnt das ganze Fahrzeug.
Wird die sofort dagegen ja da eigentlich müsste man das gar nicht so verkehrt.
Das noch zu vermengen ne noch irgendwas und tun gegen Online-Voting und Ausländer.
Ja also da.
Und und und Lügenpresse.
Ja also wir haben ja letzte Mal schon.
Elgenau ganz kurz und das Argument also du musst jedes mal erklären warum das schlecht ist während jetzt irgendwie
andere Themen kriegst du schneller erklärt wo die Leute dann sagen okay
einleuchtend dazu habe ich schon eine Meinung ich muss jetzt nicht noch das erklärt bekommen und das wird bei 100000 Unterschriften online E-Voting.
Nicht unbedingt so sein weil du da dann eben den Leuten deine erklären muss warum sie dagegen sein sollen warum sie es überhaupt deine,
ezt wieder.
Da gibt's hier einen guten Trick ja also an dieser Stelle zahlt sich das nerdtum mal voll aus weil was normalerweise was passiert denn
wenn man Leuten irgendwie versucht außerdem Nerd Welt was ganz kompliziertes zu erklären da kommt das Loch von fast von
technischen Informationen mit ganz viel Abkürzung Ja und alle gleich so ich muss weg ne
weil es wird sicher keine anhören aber hier kannst ja genau umdrehen kannst sagen na ja E-Voting ich kann ja mal erklären wie das funktioniert und du sagst mir ob du das verstanden hast und wenn du es nicht verstanden.
Dann weißt du wieso dagegen wüsste.
Genau so also da ist schon da ist schon was zu holen und allein allein weil man das,
genau Airline wenn man das schon mit einer gewissen Selbstironie auch spielen kann.
Genau deshalb.
Hunderttausend ich meine das ist echt ganz schön viel Mann ich habe gerade mal nachgeschlagen offizielle Einwohnerzahl der Schweiz wenn ich mich jetzt hier nicht getäuscht habe die gerade mal bei 8,5 Millionen.
100000 das ist ja das ist ja Prozent quasi.
Also gerade wenn du jetzt schon schon viel mehr.
Ja vorallem wo triffst du die Hunderttausende.
Ich habe malexander Schatz das Kind schon
und dann hast du ja noch hier ne verschiedene Sprachen lalala und so also findet das interessante kann das schwer nachvollziehen wir sind ja hier gewohnt immer innerhalb eines doch weit
dient vereinheitlichen Kulturraums er mit Einschränkung zu argumentieren so aber da trifft ja natürlich dann in gewisser Hinsicht nicht nur so eine deutsch,
Artikel Kultur ganz vorsichtig,
und nur Französisch Artikel Kultur aufeinander Sven nicht so ganz klar wie einheitlich man da auch argumentieren kann generell meine ich jetzt bald durch folgsam.
Also auf jeden Fall schon mal andere Sprache.
In diesem Fall in diesem Fall ist es glaube ich ganz okay wollt ihr wollt ihr das Diktat der Computernetz nein dann,
bitte unterschreiben besser so.
Von Tiedemann eine Gebrauchtwagen kaufen.
Okay moving on.
Diana Nerds die immer Nerven das ist echt interessant also haben wir diese ganze.
App Store Kultur jetzt seit 10 11 12 Jahren und der gestartet 2008 11 Jahre.
Und.
Küssen er ist im Moment das iPhone ist doch gerade erst 10 geworden dann kann der App Store ja noch nicht.
Das iPhone ist 2007 rausgekommen 2008 der App Store.
Im August September so das heißt.
Ich bin mir sicher du weißt das ja genau.
Ich weiß sehr genau weil wir.
Du weißt doch genau wo du warst.
Ja ich weiß ja genau wo ich weiß wann ich mich in Kanada und wir waren ja mit dem Blinkenlights in Kanada einer der ersten überhaupt ne Ende Apps im AppStore hatten.
Blinkenlights hatte eine App im App Store.
Ja so kannst du Dir quasi auf deinem Telefon live genau denselben Datenstrom visualisieren in 3D der auf dem Haus zu sehen war das war ganz schön verziert.
Wer hat das denn gemacht.
Hatte Dominik und der Mob haben das probiert hier die clothing Monkeys die können das.
Ja die können programmieren.
Die können probieren vor dem Konsum.
Martin pittenauer und Dominik Wagner.
Dominik Wagner genau.
Hundeblick Nerv gemacht.
Sie hatte blicnet gemacht und das war ziemlich etwa ernst so und da,
damals war das auch noch so dass du dann irgendwie eingereicht hast und wir so uns gefragt haben na ja wann wird den Apple da den Segen erteilen und damals war das ja noch ganz easy weiß er noch nicht diesen riesen Ansturm gab und es hieß so naja ne Woche vorher wird schon irgendwie reichen
dementsprechend haben wir auch eine Woche vor dem Event eingereicht und siehe da Glück gehabt ist tatsächlich durchgekommen,
hat er noch funktioniert ja diesen BBC BBC discoveries channel Bericht,
marfeldingen da ist das zu sehen ist ja auch egal auf jeden Fall da wurde dieser App Store gegründet.
Und mit dem AppStore kam neue Gepflogenheiten in der Softwareverteilung über die bis heute,
aus gutem Grund viel diskutiert wird nämlich vor allem eben dieses Prinzip eines kuratierten und,
naja mit Gatekeeper Funktion ausgestatteten Vertriebsweg bisher was ja immer so so fährt man sich einfach runtergeladen Doppelklick läuft ne,
bzw es gab auch so Stores schon auch die wieder den Zugang erleichtern wollten oder zu müssen gewisse kuratorische Funktion hatten aber es gab jetzt keinerlei Restriktionen auf Systemebene woher
so verkommen kann wenn es in für das Betriebssystem inakzeptables Format war.
Und dann hat das gereicht und Apple hat jetzt mit dem AppStore im Prinzip zuerst mal Schranken eingeführt und das ganze kryptographisch auch abgesichert spricht eine App die sich auf dem telefon auf dem iPhone nur dann starten
wenn sie eben kryptografisch signiert ist von Apple das heißt.
Für vorallem von Apple für dieses Gerät ne.
Für dieses genau für dieses also erstmal generell von Apple im Sinne von das ist eine App die wir kennen und dann eben auch dieses das darf jetzt aber auch auf deinem Telefon konkret laufen hast du nämlich gekauft.
Genau diese Sicherung das darf auf diesem Gerät laufen das ist die Sicherung gegen,
letztendlich Raubkopieren denn das was Apple da getan hat also es war
auf eine Weise wundert man sich das nicht schon jemand früher drauf gekommen ist das so zu tun
weil das ja eine wahnsinnige ein Wahnsinn ist Geld ist was da drin ist Apple hat im Prinzip neues in der neue Gerätekategorie erfunden dieses Telefon hat gesagt ok da soll jetzt Software drauf schauen wir uns irgendwie
die Welt der Softwareverteilung an was gefällt uns daran nicht ja print primär gefällt uns daran nicht Raubkopien.
Wir wollen mit dieser mit dieser Software Vertriebsplattform Geld machen indem ich die nehmen ja 30% ne.
Von jedem jeder Map verkauft er das stattfindet.
Und auch jedem in-app Verkauf.
Und genau jeder Umsatz über den Apple App Store geht 30% an Apple was er total würdest du auf dem Computerbereich hättest du das wahrscheinlich nicht akzeptiert ne Software nur aus einer Quelle.
Der der Betreiber des online dieses der Software dieser Software Quelle nimmt Geld von jedem einzelnen und ist ja dann auch am Ende veräppeln eine Milliarden.
Na was heißt nicht akzeptiert also ist ja ist ja jetzt nicht.
Kein Computer kaufen wo das so wäre.
Wenn ich dir welche Laden ginge und dann leg ein schönes MacBook und dann steht dran hier alles Software nur aus zentralen Repository will ich sagen ok was haben wir denn sonst noch so hier stehen für Geräte.
Ja gut das gibt da zwei Perspektiven es gibt da die User Perspektive und es gibt er die Entwickler Perspektive diyoza Perspektive,
wie auch die Entwickler Pilz Free-TV vielfältig also man kann aus guten Grund die Position einnehmen die du es gerade geäußert hast die ist ja auch absolut gegen ich und auf dem
Computern im Sinne von nicht iPhone nicht iOS ist es ja auch nach wie vor so da kannst du ja nach wie vor Software aus allen Quellen installieren weil da war es ja auch immer schon so.
Bei uns war es ja noch nie Landers.
Genau da konnte da deswegen konnte Apple da jetzt mit dieser neuen Gerätekategorie diesem neuen Universum,
dass sie da jetzt geschaffen haben eben die Regeln neu erfinden neu diktieren und man ich finde man erkennt schon sehr genau dass sie das eben getan haben.
Mit einer mit einer relativ kleinen Überlegung ja dass das eben Beine,
also dass sie da eben eine zentrale marktbeherrschende Stellung in ihrem eigenen Markt haben der also ich hätte ich hätte wahrscheinlich nicht anders gemacht an Apple stell und es hat ja auch.
Es hat ja auch positive Begleiterscheinungen,
das Apple da so hinterher ist nämlich das des Gerätes die EOS Plattform eine relativ komme später und hat für von Malware sehr gut,
relativ geringe MyWay Probleme hat also Chartsoftware einfach weil.
Das Ausführen einer Schadsoftware auf dem iPhone nur unter Umgehung von Sicherheitsmaßnahmen möglich ist
die Apple relativ gut pflegt einfach nur weil
Iris zentrales Geschäftsmodell ist das Raubkopieren eben auf diesen Geräten nicht möglich sind und Raubkopie ist quasi nicht nichts anderes als code
auszuführen auf dem Gerät obwohl Apple das nicht möchte dann und genau das ist eigentlich,
eben sehr schwer und davon profitieren wir da daneben dass es relativ wenig Chartsoftware gibt weil es relativ wenige Möglichkeiten gibt
Software ohne Genehmigung von Apple auf dem Gerät laufen zu lassen aber es gibt.
Ja es gibt auch noch andere gibt dann halt auch noch Vorteile für bleibe erstmal bei den Vorteilen ja Nachteile hat das ganze natürlich auch vor gar nicht verschweigen aber warum generell das auch so eine Akzeptanz gefunden hat
hat jetzt du hast ja vorhin schon diese 30% angesprochen ist ja nicht so dass Apple da nur die Hand aufhalten sollen sie,
tun ja auch was dafür ja also ob das jetzt ein angemessener Preis ist das sei jetzt mal dahingestellt aber immerhin diese ganze Verteilungen diese Installationen die Autorisierung seine alles Dinge die Softwareentwickler vorher halt haben in irgendeiner Form selber,
durchführen müssen was ja auch nicht ohne Kosten ist eine Salze Hessel mit Seriennummer Vergabe und so weiter unter dem Rock
inzwischen bisschen einzuschränken was auch nur begrenzt hilft ganzen bezahlungs Wege etc,
später kam er dann eben auch noch diese regelmäßigen Zahlungen runter dieses subscription Modelle die immer populärer wer,
woher willst auch Apples Anteil dann machen ja runter geht auf 15% aber dass man so nur so nebenbei.
Also das ganze ist so ein Gesamtpaket das muss man jetzt erstmal so akzeptieren das ist halt da ja.
Kannst auch nicht nichts anderes machen.
Es ist halt so das hat positive Auswirkungen
für Entwickler bei den Sachen abgenommen werden weil in gewisser Hinsicht Apple auch sicherstellt dass eben sie nicht beschissen werden geklaute Software da Kopien copycat Software RC gibt's alles immer irgendwie noch aber es gibt ziemlich man Mittel dagegen
und den Security respekt hast du auch schon angesprochen für die User ist es dann wiederum one stop solution es gibt nur einen Ort wo das herkommen kann alles schön.
Genau es gibt auch nur einen Ort für die Updates herkommen ja das hatte er hatte sehr schöne,
es hat es hat mir sehr schöne Nutzerfreundlichkeit jetzt aber natürlich nicht vergessen warum ich da also was ich interessant finde ist.
Also zentrale Software Repositories das eigentlich alles Software aus einer Quelle kommt,
und diese Quelle irgendwie autoritativ für die Betriebssystem Version ist oder so das gab's ja schon weiß ich nicht wie viele Jahre vorher in den in der ganzen freien Software
Wer ist ja bei FreeBSD installierst du die Software im Prinzip aus denen aus der einen großen,
Port Quelle bei den ganzen Linux-Distributionen kannst du von der Kommandozeile einfach ne in der App installieren ja was jetzt irgendwie auf Windows und,
Macintosh Geräten nie wirklich der Fall war ja das gesagt wird achso ich will mal irgendwie hier Software installieren du gibst einfach ein Befehl eine das installier jetzt bitte diese Software und der holt die und installiert die das war,
die Idee war ja schon längst da nur dann zu sagen ach geil da Knoten dir jetzt dann eine grafische User-Interface dran und eine und eine Abrechnung und unserer CDN und dann nehmen wir den Entwicklern.
Ordentlich Geld ab das war halt eine kaufmännische sehr kluge Entscheidung.
Ja und halt diese ganze Kryptographie das heißt hier wird halt auch umfangreich Konto Graphie betrieben und da, jetzt auch mal ein bisschen genauer drauf weil das ist jetzt eigentlich der Fall,
oder ist Mama ist ein interessantes Detail mit dem Fall von face.
Facebook haben wir ja hier auch als Dauerbrenner ist von Unternehmen naja mit soll ich sagen etwas schwierigen falschen Grundeinstellung,
zur Welt und facebook ist immer an Daten interessiert,
das kann man ihm nicht verübeln das sind ja eigentlich alle irgendwie dran interessiert weil wer viele Daten hat und der Lage ist sie auszuwerten kann sie dafür sich unter Umständen nutzbar machen Facebook ist er halt immer besonders an Daten interessiert die von den Usern
und es kann ihn nicht genug sein und so haben sie dann vor einiger Zeit mal eine app gekauft von einem VPN Provider owano.
Onavo und schon wieder ohne,
genau onavo und das war im Prinzip so ein typischer VPN Provider Apps wo die gibt's ja vielfältig man lädt sich so die App runter und dann sagt die app so jetzt hier,
kannst du dich hier verbinden kostenlosen zuviel Geld pro Monat,
dann geht meine ganze Daten dann deine ganzen Daten gehen dann irgendwie uns unseren Provider und kommt irgendwo anders im Internet raus und von dort verbindest du dich nur zur Umgehung von regionalen Einschränkungen von Firewall sitze.
Also streckenweise wird auch noch irgendwie gesagt ach ja wir wir sperren irgendwann noch einen Filter mit drin ja wir sperren irgendwelche.
Was heißt negativ Erscheinung des Netzes oder mit uns ist es schneller ja weil wir eben Caching Proxy dazu haben oder so also die VPNs versuchen ja alle möglichen
Dinge irgendwie zu finden oder zu bewerben damit Leute da ihren,
Traffic durchleiten und das große Problem bei VPN ist aber eben auch genau dass das daneben die in der in der Position sind dich dein treffe.
Zu kontrollieren die können den aufzeichnen die können umleiten und,
deswegen muss man seinen VPN-Anbieter Weise wählen oder.
Ja dann werden die Quali zum Internet-Service-Provider für ein ne also die Daten verlassen dann quasi bei denen eigentlich erst so den Heimathafen und gehen ins Weite Netz,
brachte sich so Facebook na lass doch nur super Idee dann benutzen wir das doch einfach mal damit Leute das benutzen
um einfach normal Internet zu machen und wir zahlen den dann einfach Geld dafür dass sie das tun leiten das aber alles durch unsere Netze
und dann schauen wir uns das dann aber auch mal ganz genau an was die denn da so tun wenn daraus können wir dann sozusagen
Benutzer Verhalten analysieren und frühzeitig erkennen wo denn der Trend so hingeht sprich rausfinden was benutzen die Leute für Apps auf welche Art und Weise benutzen Sie diese Apps mit welchen Webseiten wird hier kommuniziert wie viel werden Messenger benutzt wie viel wird dieses und jenes benutzt also
das war so das Ziel.
Das ist das ist aber weil ich weiß wie krass das ist ja diese die mit ihrem scheiß Facebook die Leute sind doch eh schon den ganzen Tag nur noch da drauf ja dann.
Facebook tut alles um an die Daten dieser Nutzer zu kommen dann haben einer der besten Ideen die sie irgendwie vor vielen Jahren natürlich halten weil dieser Facebook Like-Button ne wo sie gesagt haben,
bitte bitte bitte liebe Seitenbetreiber bettet diesen Code in eurer Webseite nein damit jedesmal wenn jemand eure blöde Webseite besucht der auch noch
ein von uns ein Stück Kotelett damit wir wissen dass eure dass unsere Nutzer gerade bei euch auf der Seite sind und wissen,
was andere Leute machen die nicht unsere Nutzer sind ja und,
es ist es ist einfach geil was sie sich einfallen lassen dass sie immer nur davon getrieben sind neue Daten zu bekommen,
die sie nicht ohnehin schon haben das ist eigentlich der inkomplettes denn komplette,
Ausrichtung dieses Unternehmens das machen den ganzen Tag sich überlegen wo kriegen wir noch mehr Daten her.
Genau also deswegen haben sie 2014 eben onavo gekauft und navo wiederum hat sozusagen den Leuten versprochen naja wenn er uns benutzt dann dünn wir irgendwie deinen Daten
Volumen soweit aus und optimieren hier deinen Zugang ist weniger von deinen Datenverbrauch
also auch hier wieder hohe Preise zwingen die Leute zu skurrilen verhalten.
Und naja Apple ist dann irgendwann aber auf den Trichter gekommen was hier läuft und hat das ganze ich glaube im Juni letzten Jahres abgeschaltet weil,
das schlicht und ergreifend den Regeln die sie da formuliert haben widerspricht mit.
Welchen welche Waffe was genau.
Den Privatsphäre ja du hast hier nicht du hast hier nicht die User auszuleuchten.
Achso weil die achso apple hatte da genau das wissen wie oft du vielleicht noch kurz erklären Apple hat relativ strenge Vorgaben Regeln und Kontrollen was,
eine App überhaupt von dem ge von den Nutzern und von dem Gerät wissen darf also das wird
du kannst z.b. nicht als fa feststellen ob FB installiert ist oder du kriegst keine you ID des Gerätes Apple ist da relativ oder du kriegst keine
wenn du nach einer you ID des Gerätes fragst dann kriegst du eine die für deine App die you id dieses Gerätes ist,
so dass du nicht korrelieren kannst an an anderen Stellen und da quasi Daten zusammenführen.
Genau oder die MAC-Adresse die wir letztes Mal so schön besprochen haben.
Genau MAC-Adressen kriegst du nicht.
Gibt es auch nicht also privacy war Apple dann immer wichtiger über die Jahre und das hat mittlerweile enorm zugenommen und in dem Zuge ist daneben auch diese App onavo von,
Apple verboten und dann auch aus dem AppStore.
Weil sie weil sie weil ihr Modell war den dd Datenanalyse zumachen und gesagt hat okay hier leitet mal allen Traffic durch uns wir gucken uns den dann an und hat Apple gesagt ne solche Geschäftsmodelle unterstützen ihr nicht.
Okay.
Also den Bericht von TechCrunch wird auch vermutet dass diese App auch dazu geführt hat dass sie schnell gesehen haben dass Whatsapp so populär wird die haben sehr dann,
2014 auch gekauft.
Ja und dann dachte sich Facebook oder selber scheiße wenn man jetzt irgendwie diese App nicht mehr haben weil das hat uns doch hier so geile Tipps gegeben das hat sich doch mal voll gelohnt,
und dann machen wir das doch einfach mal trotzdem wie können wir denn jetzt diese App an die Leute bekommen auf iOS wenn.
Wenn Apple da was dagegen hat jetzt ist es so dass große Unternehmen nicht unbedingt für alles,
immer diesen Weg des App-Stores direkt nehmen müssen sondern große Unternehmen wobei groß weiß ich es ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz genau wo es anfängt also wenn man ein Unternehmen ist kann man auf jeden Fall das Beantragen nämlich ein sogenanntes,
Enterprise certificate sprich Apple erlaubtes unter Auflagen wiederum Unternehmen,
Software direkt auf Telefone zu distribuieren ohne dass das durch diesen AppStore Prozess läuft.
Wenn diese Telefone vorher als gehören zu diesem Unternehmen markierte
kriegt man dann so ein kleines Zertifikat eingespielt das muss man dann bestätigen und sagen so ja alles klar hier ist das Facebook Enterprise Zertifikat dieses Telefon ist jetzt offiziell Teil dieses Unternehmens
und wenn dann halt eine Software von Facebook intern verteilt wird für dieses Telefon,
oder dieses iOS Device dann kann das eben direkt zum Laufen gebracht werden und das wird,
einerseits benutzt für so interne Apps,
das weiß ich da bestellen da die Mitarbeiter irgendwie Kollektiv hier essen oder halt machen Kapu legen oder 1000 Beispiele was auch immer man sozusagen als firmeninterne Anwendung auf dieser Plattform,
hör ansieht und haben möchte dann kann man dass ich das selber entwickeln und entsprechend verteilen ohne jedesmal Apple fragen zu müssen dann ist das halt einfach dein Ding weil bleibt ja in deinem Unternehmen ist nicht für die Öffentlichkeit,
einerseits andererseits kann man aber auch diesen Beta-Test Prozess,
natürlich dadurch sehr viel einfacher machen das heißt die Vielzahl von Apps die Facebook so rausbringt instagram,
WhatsApp die Facebook App Messenger also der ganze Kram ich weiß nicht was sie noch alles am Start haben bei was weiß ich wie 400000 Mitarbeitern die die mittlerweile haben.
Lohnt sich das natürlich früher Beta-Version von Software die die Öffentlichkeit sei so auch noch gar nicht sehen soll einfach erstmal firmenintern zu testen und der komplette Entwicklungsprozess ist daneben auch dahingehend,
optimiert dass man ebenso eine Verteilung macht.
Jetzt dachte sich so Facebook na ja ist doch super dann brauchen wir doch den Leuten diese wo wir den mal die Daten schauen wollen eigentlich nur so ein blödes Zertifikat installieren dann können wir unsere blöde überwachungs App da direkt aufspielen,
Mama das war einfach mal damit die Leute bereit sind diesen Aufwand aufzutreiben geben die nicht uns Geld sollen wir geben denen Geld,
hier hast du Zwanni pro Monat hauptsache wir können mal deine Daten machen.
Es wirklich geil.
Beende Anbieter bezahlt dich.
Vermieter Daten sendest da dreht sich alles schön um und nicht nur das es geht ja gar nicht mal nur um die Daten nein sie waren dann sogar noch so frech und haben,
auch noch ein zusätzliches SSL root Zertifikat installiert damit,
eben dieser Datentraffic nicht nur bei ihnen landet sein dass sie dann eben auch serverseitig auch die ganzen https Sachen mit so einer man in the middle Attacke übernehmen und daneben auch noch auslesen kann,
also es ist wirklich an das ist echt kaum noch zu überbieten an Frechheit den Leuten.
Im Wesentlichen dann wahrscheinlich Jugendliche ja die freut sich so auf 20 $ Monaten soll ich das nicht das Gleiche machen wir sonst auch ist ja hier auch schnell genug mit facebook Netzwerk
für sie ist alles genauso wie vorher kriegen bloß 20 $ im Monat da kann man sich halt einiges von leisten wenn man nicht so viel Kohle hat als Kind,
dementsprechend interessant ist das ja und so lief das dann wohl eine Weile und.
Jetzt kam aber da ein entsprechender Bericht raus bei TechCrunch und das ganze wurde öffentlich,
und Apple dachte sich so,
bitte und was ist jetzt nicht irgendwie irgendeine andere App soll das ist genau die App die Apple vor explizit verboten hatte,
ja immer noch mit denselben developments bringst da drin und so weiter also sie haben sich gar nicht große Mühe gegeben das auch nur irgendwie anders zu verschleiern
Ja und Direktion von Apple war ziemlich eindeutig die haben halt einfach den Stöpsel gezogen und Facebook das komplette Enterprise Zertifikat
gesperrt woraufhin all diese ganzen
Essensbestellung und Carb Pudding Alps und die ganze Beta development Geschichte nicht mehr funktionierte von heute auf morgen.
Ja aber ist doch richtig so also dafür dafür haben die dort im Zweifelsfall den Vertrag über die Nutzung dieses Enterprise Tertianer wird den Apple doch auch eine längere Papyrusrolle terms of services hingelegt haben in den drin steht das
das nicht vorgesehen ist wie sie es getan haben.
Ja natürlich klar also ich meine dass ich denke facebook hat ja Ali auf mehreren Ebenen gegen alles mögliche verstoßen na also erstmal haben sie ja schon mal die rote Karte gezeigt bekommen für diese App und daneben auch noch die Traute zu haben genau dieselbe Software die schon auf dem AppStore nicht
okay war
die dann auch noch auf diesem Wege zu vertreiben und das dann weil sie geheim in den in den Regeln steht natürlich nicht wieder ganze privacy und Sicherheits Graben drin,
da steht dann für dich vor allem drin du darfst nur.
Schatz Software damit hin oder aufbringen.
Ja weil du darfst auch nur innerhalb des eigenen Unternehmens ist una und das war halt definitiv nicht der Fall dementsprechend hat Apple einfach mal den Schalter umgelegt und schwupps ist dann auf einmal alles tot ja sie hätten im Prinzip wohl auch,
nur diese eine App killen können aber da Facebook generell hier gegen die Regeln verstoßen hat na ja.
Dingsda gleich richtig zur Sache ungefähr zeitgleich kam dann auch noch Google an,
mit einem ganz kleinen lauten Blogpost weil die haben nämlich auch so eine App.
Stikeez dann screenwise war aber jetzt nicht ganz so böse was sie mir ganz.
Na ja ist ja da keine damit nicht so gut Zertifikat installiert und noch mal den ganzen verschlüsselten traffic,
ausgelesen aber sie hatten im Prinzip auch so einem Monitor in App die auch nach draußen gehen und das kann dann schnell raus und obwohl der Fall bei Google nicht ganz so krass war wie es bei Facebook,
hatte auch Google ein Tag später,
kein Enterprise Zertifikat mehr auf iOS was heißt bei den größten größten Internetunternehmen dieser Welt lag die komplette iOS Entwicklung vollständig brav und nebenbei können die Mitarbeiter sich irgendwie keine,
keine Karten abholen und keine Pizza mehr Kollektiv.
Aber das der hat allerdings leider nicht lange angehalten oder.
Nein das hat nicht lange angehalten also das ganze ging dann ein oder zwei Tage.
Oder sind natürlich dann die man sich vorstellen kann Gespräche geführt worden und es ist sicherlich jetzt auch nicht.
Absehbar gewesen dass dieser Zustand ewig so anhalten.
Hört sich so ein bisschen ungerecht weil hätte man jetzt als kleiner thailändischer software developer dieselbe Nummer durchgezogen.
Dann wäre es wahrscheinlich bei Apple Air auf dem Band vorläufigen ausgelaufen,
hatte schon mehrfach dass da entsprechende versucht wurde mal mehr ran zu bringen oder zumindest die Privatsphäre der Nutzer ordentlich aus zu horchen
und das führte dann relativ schnell zum dauerhaften permanenten sperren bestimmter Personen die dann nicht Schwierigkeiten haben.
Das hätte ich echt begrüßt ja.
Ja gut ich meine man muss natürlich jetzt zweimal.
Köln Kalk Verbot für Facebook.
Man muss jetzt zwei live sehen ne wäre du halt bei einem einzelnen Entwickler im Wesentlichen ist auch nur mit dieser einen Person zu tun hast ja die dann auch an allem schuld ist kann man jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen dass bei Facebook,
alle daran schuld sind klar als Unternehmen,
dafür ist es ja eins die Chefs haben da falsch entschieden ne keine Ahnung welche Köpfe da gerollt sind keine Ahnung was der Deal ist darüber ist,
mir zumindest noch nichts genaueres zu Ohren gekommen aber da so ganz Konsequenzen frei wird das sicherlich auch nicht gewesen sein.
Keine Ahnung von wo oben das ganze so indiziert wurde ob das etwas direkt von Zuckerberg Tisch war oder ob das auf ner zweiten oder dritten Ebene entschieden wurde keine Ahnung aber es ist natürlich auch klar,
das wenn Apple jetzt sagt okay das war's dann.
Jetzt kein Facebook kein Messenger kein Instagram und kein WhatsApp mehr auf iOS.
Kannst du in etwa vorstellen wieso das Verständnis bei den Usern dafür so wäre.
Ich will ich finde super ja ich finde echt spitze aber vielleicht.
Vielleicht wäre ich da nicht bei der Mehrheit.
Ja aber du bist halt auch kein Unternehmen was irgendwie seinen Kundensupport über WhatsApp macht du bist.
Keine Familienunternehmen was irgendwie alle sein ganzes Shopping über Facebook betreibt also du würdest ja in dem Moment und das zeigt natürlich auch die Abhängigkeiten beide Richtungen sehr schön du würdest natürlich unzählige,
Unternehmungen aller Art die würde ich mit diesem Fall mit einem konkreten Fall vor allem nicht zu tun haben also gar nichts mit ins Verderben ziehen,
ja also von daher ist das natürlich hier eine Abwehr.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht ob ich das Abschalten von Facebook als verderben bezeichnen würde aber ja.
Gibt einfach viele viele Unternehmen die die Leben einfach auf Facebook die dir machen da Ihr Business dass dass das ist ihre Internetplattform das können wir scheiße finden.
Aber das ist so so und genauso ist WhatsApp für viele Leute einfach.
Eine wichtige kommunikationsfähig weil sie ja mir ist nicht die Apps bei den Leuten gelöscht ja hier ging es ja sozusagen nur um das aus spiel also.
Facebook hätte nach wie vor ein WhatsApp Update rausgeben können,
nur der Weg dahin wäre dorniger gewesen deutlich dorniger als,
also hätte Apple hätte Facebook jetzt überhaupt keinerlei interne Enterprise Distribution machen können das hätte wahrscheinlich Wochen gedauert bis sie überhaupt der Lage gewesen wären,
irgendein Beta Zyklus zu starten und ein neues Feature rauszubringen bei dem sie sich sicher sind dass es nicht bei den Leuten zur totalen Chaos führt und das,
ist halt ein Abwägen also ich glaube nicht dass das jetzt wirklich jemals zur Diskussion stand Facebook zusammen komplett,
aus dem AppStore zu jagen ja oder sie auf alle Ewigkeit zu bestrafen aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass die Straflager schon relativ groß ist allein,
die paar Tage kompletter Vernichtung der Softwareentwicklung.
Herr Hase.
Eine Menge Geld gekostet haben.
Ehrlich gesagt würde ich sagen jetzt haben wir lange genug über dieses Thema gesprochen weil.
So viel scheint jetzt irgendwie nicht passiert zu sein was können wir lernen Facebook missbraucht jede Möglichkeit die sie haben.
Und schreckt vor irgendwie überhaupt nichts zurück,
inklusive Leute weil es ja wenigstens auch mal eine faire Sache ist jetzt hat wenigstens Facebook mal die Leute für ihre Daten bezahlt ja normalerweise ja also das muss man auch mal sein das ist ja immerhin immerhin.
Ja ja dann müssen es du immer machen jede jeder Facebook Lite 20.
Jeder 40 € Entschädigung im Monat für,
Daten toom her und dann okay Apple kontrolliert sein seinen App-Store aber dann auch da offenbar eben mit Ja,
unterschiedlich unterschiedlichem Maß ja dass sie nämlich weil größere andere Unternehmen hätten sicherlich keine zweite Chance bekommen oder so.
Und dann wird irgendwie groß gefeiert hahaha facebook hatte jetzt übers Wochenende mal kein Enterprise Zertifikat ja jetzt irgendwie auch nicht so.
So wahnsinnig also ich will nicht,
dieses App-Store Geschäftsmodell ist interessant es ist offene also es ist deshalb interessant weil es wird.
Genial offene Weise ist in diesem Unternehmen halt der also die Idee das so zu tun hat dem Unternehmen halt Milliarden eingebracht
das hat Vorteile für die generelle Sicherheit dieser Plattformen es ist ein Netz ein Nebeneffekt davon dass sie eben.
Dieses ist diese Systeme zur Bekämpfung von Raubkopien so zu machen dass es eben als Folge auch hat dass die dass es relativ,
hohe Hürden gibt für schachsoftware aber offenbar sind die würden nicht hoch genug das nicht Facebook denn noch alles tun würde um eine Schatz so sehr auf die Geräte.
Sowas wenn man schon bei Facebook sind wie ich ja schon sagte,
im Prinzip das dass das Tagesgeschäft bei Facebook in der in der Entwicklung ist neue Wege zu finden wie man an irgendwelche Daten von ihr welche Leuten kommt ja und dazu gehörte natürlich auch die Anschaffung von,
Instagram und,
WhatsApp beides Unternehmen die sich Facebook irgendwann gekauft hat ich glaube Instagram Wasser was war das noch mal so eine Milliarde oder sowas.
Und WhatsApp glaube ich für 19 Milliarden oder das war WhatsApp haben die richtig richtig viel Geld für gelassen.
Und da fragt man sich natürlich warum kaufen die,
warum kaufen die für so viel Geld diese Unternehmen na ja so ein bisschen um die eigene macht halt zu zementieren um sicher zu sein dass sie jetzt nicht auf einmal WhatsApp so groß und so reich wird dass sie Facebook,
was ist tatsächlich Konkurrenz machen und natürlich weil es eine weitere Datenquelle ist,
sehr überrascht waren wir ja dann alle als Facebook relativ kurz nach der Anschaffung von Whatsapp im Rahmen dieser ganzen Snowden Diskussionen gesagt hat okay wir nehmen die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung des
das Messenger Signal das Axolotl Protokoll oder wie das heißt der,
ich denke jetzt irgendeine ich muss jetzt auch.
Weissinger jetzt mal so.
Ja
Da komme ich jetzt durcheinander.
Der hat doch ehemalig ist das herzlich axollo.
Früher Axolotl ja ich habe oder.
Wieso bist du das.
Okay wunderbar weil es wird jetzt Axolotl Axolotl Protokoll hieß das früher irgendwann mit den Entwicklern diese.
Warum hast du das eigentlich absolut oder wenn es kann man im Protokoll jederzeit ein Bein ausreißen und es wächst dann nach.
Ich habe keine Ahnung warum der so genannt.
Da deutet ja auch so eine gewisse Resilienz vielleicht hin.
Ja die okay wie dem auch sei also dieser diese Möglichkeit der Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung wurde eben.
Mithilfe von den Entwicklern von von Signal Moxie marlinspike.
Dann auch auf WhatsApp rübergebracht ja so dass Whatsapp eben auch Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung hatte was er damals eine relativ krasser move war ja weil vorher konnte ja quasi diese ganzen Nachrichten einsehen,
Ja und haben das natürlich auch getan und jetzt sich diese Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung haben sie im Prinzip gesagt für immer ade,
zu diesen Kommunikations Inhalten die natürlich für facebook will man eigentlich meinen interessant,
waren aber quasi diese Möglichkeit der der das Vertrauen wieder herzustellen um diesen diesen Messenger irgendwie Snowden.
Post Norden kompatibel zu machen haben sie eben diesen diesen Schritt damals getan gleichzeitig hat das aber auch natürlich gezeigt,
was ja auch eine der entscheidenden Lehren aus nordenwall der Meter Datenüberwachung eben
wieso viel mächtiger ist als inhaltsbasiert Überwachung und das ist offenbar für für Facebook eben reicht diese Metadaten zu haben.
Und das mit ihrem neunzehn Milliarden Investment zumindest Inhalte Verschlüsselung nicht so schlimm ist dass sie es nicht machen würden.
Und jetzt hatten wir also die Situation.
Das muss ja dann auch glaube ich von Kartellbehörden geprüft werden ob es ob Facebook dieses WhatsApp kaufen darf oder nicht
und WhatsApp Facebook hat damals ganz klar gesagt nee nee wir führen diese Daten nicht zusammen
ja wir www die Leute sind zwar WhatsApp Kunde die sind Facebook Hunde und die sind von mir aus auch noch Instagram Kunde aber wir merken jetzt diese Accounts nicht ja wir lassen das die gehören und zwar beide diese Unternehmen,
wir müssen die aber nicht den wir wir wir versuchen die nicht gegenseitig einzuverleiben und jetzt stellte Facebook natürlich fest an über instagram können die Leute sich direkt Nachrichten schicken über Facebook können die Leute sich direkt Nachricht,
und über WhatsApp auch wir haben irgendwie dreimal,
drei messenger im Prinzip die die wir unterhalten drei Datenbanken in den den wir da unterschiedliche Datensammeln es wäre natürlich sehr schön das zusammenzuführen.
Lass uns mal eine Ausrede einfallen warum wir das tun warum was was machen wir welche schöne
weiß Rittern der Ausrede haben wir diese messenger zu zu kombinieren und damit unsere Nutzer Basis zu konsolidieren und die Daten von den unterschiedlichen Unternehmen die wir da haben und Diensten die wir da haben zusammenzuführen,
gerne zu Ende Verschlüsselung hier und dann geht Dir ja.
Ist der Zuckerberg tatsächlich vor dir vor die Presse gegangen hat gesagt ja die sind wir bringen ja hier die Privatsphäre und die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung in die Breite,
Klammer auf das muss man natürlich Facebook auch sagen der,
die Implementierung des Sydney Protokolls auf WhatsApp war wahrscheinlich die historisch größte,
größte Ausrollen von Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung was die Menschheit wahrscheinlich hier gesehen hat und wahrscheinlich auch ein langer Zeit,
sehen wir beide keine App und keine Kommunikationstechnik vorher so viele Nutzer Rennen und Nutzer hatte und gleichzeitig.
Und dann jetzt eine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung hatte also der die die die die die am meisten verbreitete Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Form der Kommunikation ist dieses WhatsApp das,
schon ein ein krasser Schritt der da getan wurde und aufjedenfall denen im Facebook jetzt sagt ja weil das so toll ist und weil wir überall jetzt den Leuten die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung bieten wollen,
merchandise Instagram Facebook Messenger und WhatsApp zu einem zu einer Plattform so dass man quasi plattformübergreifend sich da Sachen zusenden kann.
Und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt im Zweifelsfall werden sie dann nämlich sagen ja registriert auch mal für dein instagram-account auch deine Telefonnummer und weil sie braucht ja dann irgendwie so eine.
Von Adressierung ja also WhatsApp ist klar da ist deine da ist das wodota du erreicht ist deine Telefonnummer bei Facebook ist es der Facebook Account bei Instagram ist es der instagram-account was passiert jetzt wenn ich,
wenn ich eine Instagram direct Nachricht an einen WhatsApp Nutzer sende ja bin ich mal gespannt da werden wir dann irgendeine Form von,
zentrale Aldi schaffen müssen da bin ich mal gespannt wie sie das wie sie das tun werden.
Da widerspricht sich ja nicht unbedingt weil bei Whatsapp läuft das dann wissen nicht alles über die Telefonnummern und bei Facebook halt über den Facebook-Account das wird schon.
Aber die werden die müssen noch in einen einen Namespace dann haben die wären noch nicht sagen schreib mal eine WhatsApp an Facebook Account die werden ja die werden ja das Ziel wird ja sein dass Sie den Facebook Account und den WhatsApp Account und den Instagram account,
auf eine ID zusammenführen.
Ja ich denke mal das wenn senden.
TV Google das mit mit YouTube gemacht.
Das Fernsehen Leuten an halt einfach anbieten weil das ja dann so einfach ist und so und so.
Gerade werde Leuten einfach irgendeinen Overlay machen dass sie ihre Nachrichten nicht mehr ohne Frieden
lesen können und bis sie bist du der Weg gekriegt haben oder wenn sie nachher sagen alle Nutzer freuen sich dass sie dass sie ihre Accounts gemerged haben aber es warum ist das Nachrichten
warum ist das überhaupt eine Nachricht es ist eine Nachricht weil sie jahrelang gesagt haben dass sie genau das nicht tun würden und jetzt tun sich natürlich war ja auch klar.
Bleiben wir bei Überwachung.
Bayern wir bei Überwachung.
Da gab es einen Vorfall beim.
Bundesverfassungsgericht nehme ich eine Beschwerde ein von einiger Zeit und zwar von dem Unternehmen,
posteo denn posteo wiederum hatte also passiert ist ja eine E-Mail Anbieter in Deutschland der darauf,
der damit wirbt besonders datensparsam umzugehen also möglichst wenig Informationen von seinen Kunden zu erfragen und auch ein Betrieb zu speichern,
um eine gewisse Privatsphäre zu groß zu halten wie es geht manchmal.
Garantieren jetzt nicht Anonymität oder so aber halt sich da eben zurück und dass es Sohn sagt man so schön ein USP,
von Ihrem Produkt.
Einen Jungen an unique selling proposition etwas warum man das W nun gab es aber wieder irgendeinen kriminellen Vorfall und die Staatsanwaltschaft in Stuttgart ermittelte,
und traf dabei eben auch auf einen posteo Account und fragte dann bei posteo mal so an wie man das so macht als Staatsanwaltschaft ja hier gibt doch mal IP-Adressen raus und Verbindung unter denen,
dieser E-Mail Account abgefragt wurde hätten wir mal ganz gerne und mal rauszufinden wer das ist und dann posteo so na ja,
aber nicht weil so wie das bei uns technisch realisiert ist,
weiß unsere E-Mail-Anwendung überhaupt nicht mit wem da draußen kommuniziert wird weil das intern schon durch Adresse Übersetzungen anonymisiert wird quasi,
und auch diese Verbindungsdaten die quasi die richtige IP-Adresse mit der Verbindung zu dem Server intern
vorhalten werden nicht dauerhaft gespeichert sein Leben nur so temporär vorgehalten solange das eben erforderlich ist solange diese Verbindung besteht und danach einfach fallen gelassen und weg ist.
Wann die Staatsanwaltschaft in Stuttgart überhaupt nicht lustig und hat dann geklagt ist Force Amtsgericht gegangen und dann auch vors Landgericht,
in Stuttgart und das meinte dann so na ja das müsste aber posteo mal machen weil wo kommen denn da hin dann können wir ja die Leute nicht mehr überwachen.
Prowin posteo Beschwerde eben eingereicht hat beim Bundesverfassungsgericht und dieses Bundesverfassungsgericht die dritte Kammer hat jetzt beschlossen dass
die Staatsanwaltschaft das schon alles richtig gemacht hätte und das doch bitte posteo in Zukunft diese Informationen vorzuhalten hat,
und dass die Schutzwürdigkeit dieser Daten dem ja nicht im Wege stehen also mit Grundrechten und so bräuchte man ihn da jetzt nicht zu kommen denn,
posteo hätte hier schlecht die Verpflichtung eben entsprechende Informationen auch zu generieren.
Casa Wasserfall oder.
Interessantheit ich darf dir die Begründung ja so ein bisschen.
Das passt darüber dass passieren sagt die die Erhebung dieser oder diese Daten sind für unseren Betrieb nicht erforderlich.
Und
deswegen sammle wir die nicht und deswegen könnt ihr die euch auch gar nicht holen und dann hat wurde scheint ein bisschen so argumentiert worden zu sein selbstverständlich braucht man IP-Adressen um im Internet einen Dienst anzubieten,
Unfälle passiert hat gesagt nee aber man braucht sie nicht zu speichern und dann haben die jetzt irgendwie verloren und ich es scheint irgendwie so zu sein das passt ihre jetzt offen Bandidas.
Ja so bisschen nebulös gesagt wir werden auf jeden Fall nicht alle IP Adressen von allen Nutzern erheben
und ich bin jetzt mal gespannt ob die dann sagen na ja okay dann machen wir das halt bieten wir dann halt
auf Nachfrage an für einzelne Nutzer auf Richter an richterliche Anordnung die IP-Adressen zu locken oder so ich würde schätzen dass sie Fall dass sie versuchen sich aufs auf auf so eine Möglichkeit,
zurückzuziehen.
Also angeblich hat posteo jetzt einerseits ihre Überraschung.
Ja die kann ich verstehen da habe ich auch immer.
Gamze kundgetan und mein aber auch
das ist ja bisher unbestritten gewesen sei dass diese Auskunftspflicht sich nur auf Daten bezieht die tatsächlich vorliegen und jetzt würde ja dieses Urteil bedeuten dass Daten alleinig nur zur Ermittlung Zwecken erhoben werden müssen,
und die sind das irgendwie erstmal gar nicht an und ich habe das Gefühl diese Geschichte geht noch eine Weile so weiter.
Aber wenn das war doch jetzt das Bundesverfassungsgericht oder.
Ja
An wen kann man sich an wen kann man sich wo kann man sich über das Bundesverfassungsgericht beschweren.
Ja bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Delta madet das jetzt fertig oder da bist du jetzt.
Ja weiß ich nicht eine Minute loyal.
Weiß es nicht wann würde das vermuten ne.
Ich würde schätzen dass es jetzt dass das vorbei ist ja.
Ja immer dieser Fall selber ist wohl schon ansich abgeschlossen dadurch dass sie da einmal eine Strafe bezahlt haben ein Ordnungsgeld bezahlt haben.
Vielleicht nehmen sie das jetzt einfach.
So hin und sagen naja dann zweimal halt hier Ordnungsgeld dafür dass wir es nicht gemacht haben weil sie haben auch wir 500 € bezahlt.
Und eine länger laufende Überwachungsmaßnahme würde aber dann halt viel teurer sein und klar also ich kann das gerade noch nicht interpretieren welche Folgen das hat.
Aber diesen Fall gibt's und den Link dazu in den Schoner.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ärgerlich aber ich also ich würde hoffen dass posteo Nachprüfung sich daneben zu einer Datenschutz.
Spar einer datensparsam Lösung sucht mit dieser Anforderungen umzugehen ist es natürlich.
Also diese Jahr IP-Adresse ne ich meine ich kann.
Es ist ich glaube das ist vielleicht nicht schlecht wenn man wenn die Lösung am Ende darin besteht ok auf richterliche Anordnung können kann,
Patio gezwungen werden eine IP-Adresse zu erfassen auf Anfrage aber jetzt das Dienstanbieter,
verurteilt werden ja ihr wie alle Daten zu erheben werden wir gleichzeitig miteinander datenschutz-grundverordnung die lädt nämlich eigentlich unter unter Verpflichtung sind diese Daten nicht zu erheben ja also
der relativ schwierig zu sagen diese Datenschutz-Erklärung Passagen zur Speicherung von IP-Adressen in Server.log sind ja durchaus,
lang und komplex und da wir uns damit auseinandergesetzt und jetzt kommt irgendwie so ein Verfassungsgerichtsurteil was.
Da ist für mich eine andere Sprache spricht das wundert mich.
Damals nicht allein gehen da mit dem Thema beschäftigt haben verschieben wir das jetzt noch ein bisschen auf die Zukunft das weiter zu beobachten und zu interpretieren.
Gut dann sind wir.
In Österreich angelangt da gibt's einen wunderschönen amüsanten Fall gerade und zwar hat die Salzburger Arbeiterkammer eine Wahl.
Angeboten wird eine Abstimmung und dann sie gesagt sie machen wir das machen wir online machen wir wollten ja,
was könnte,
schief gehen wir machen E-Voting mit allem was daran schon falsch ist was für eine letzte Sendung erzählt haben schon und die sendung davor und dann geht ein 20-jähriger,
hör auf diese Seite und ihm fällt auf dass man dort eine 10 stellige Nummer eingeben muss nämlich die,
Sozialversicherungsnummer und von dieser zehnstellige Nummer sind 6 das Geburtsdatum.
Also ja Monat Tag dann kommen noch vier weitere Ziffern von dieser von diesen vier weiteren Ziffern ist aber eine nur eine Prüfziffer das heißt effektiv gibt es,
relevant nur noch drei weitere Ziffern,
und die kannst du natürlich relativ einfach durchprobieren ja also wenn du wenn es 10 Uhr wenn es wenn es 4 Uhr werden wir die Möglichkeit halt.
100000 und wenn es drei sind Sie die Möglichkeiten 10000,
die die man quasi durchprobieren müsste um am Ende eine valide Sozialversicherungsnummer zu prüfen
und das hat er einen genau an dieser Seite getan denn wenn man da eine gültige Sozialversicherungsnummer eingegeben hat dann hat diese diese diese Plattform die Daten dieser Person rausgegeben.
So dass du also ne nicht nur also das Ding hatte quasi von allen Personen die in dieser Arbeiterkammer sind und weil ich das richtig verstanden habe sind das alle,
die daten quasi gegen ohne weiteren Schutz gegen Sozialversicherungsnummer rausgegeben und eine Sozialversicherungsnummer war einfach zu raten jetzt hat der junge Mann sich also einfach in JavaScript geschrieben und hat gesagt jetzt zähle ich halt meine von,
von 1 bis bis 10000 hoch.
Und bzw bis 9999 und gucke mal ob ich Daten zurück bekomme.
Ja und hat natürlich Daten zurück bekommen und dann hat er diese.
Schwachstelle bei der Arbeiterkammer gemeldet hat gesagt hier na das ist ein Problem was ihr da hat kümmert euch dann mal drum dann war aber irgendwie nicht so war irgendwie nicht das Ergebnis was er sich gewünscht hat also hat er dann noch das Pferd,
eingeschaltet also das Computer emergency response Team Beschwerden.
Pizza gibt's auch in Deutschland unterhalten viele Länder das sind im Prinzip Stellen an denen man Größe größere Sicherheitsprobleme melden kann die sich jetzt Ihr wie von relevant,
von Relevanz für dieses Land sind die dann so ein bisschen,
damit mit Sachverstand und Kompetenz dann dran gehen und mit den mit den Anbietern sprechen oder so.
Daten Feuerwehr Dinos die daten Feuerwehr.
Genau die daten Feuerwehr ja dass dass das halbe Hattersheimer Hilfswerk dass das halber Hilfswerke und.
Daher hat er das denn hin gemeldet und jetzt.
Mach die Arbeiterkammer Satir wir haben ja ein Hacker gehabt.
Ja die Daten also wir wollten hier ein schönes online Wahlsystem machen und dieser Hacker hat unter Umgehung unserer Sicherheitsmaßnahmen hier Daten ausgelesen,
diskreditieren jetzt aber doch den den 20-Jährigen der nichts weiter gemacht hat als diese Schwachstelle zu sehen kurz zu bestätigen,
und den also bestätigen dass dass sie auch tatsächlich existiert ja hätte ja auch sein können dass das System nach 3 Versuchen den Nutzer sperrt oder was auch immer irgendwelche Schutzmaßnahmen hat
sie denen gemeldet hat die auch noch dem Pferd gemeldet und als danke schön wird er jetzt von denen da als,
als Krimineller beschimpft und in einer Berichterstattung wird auch gesagt sie hätten den jetzt angezeigt was ich.
Kapfinger und zwar haben sie ihn dafür angezeigt dass er auf reddit
nämlich sich Hilfe gesucht hat hat irgendwie auf Reddit geschrieben ich habe hier einen Fall von wohin soll ich mich wenden da mir meine Leute noch empfohlen ja wenn du dich an das zerrt Österreich der kannte das nämlich gar nicht also hat er die wie oft Kraft das gibt's ja auch in der Waden.
Super Empfehlung Datenschutzbehörde informiert und so weiter und jetzt,
wollen Sie ihm quasi zur Last legen dass er darüber öffentlich gesprochen hat ich bin mal sehr gespannt wie sich das wie sich das weiterentwickelt aber zu behaupten
Mann wäre gehackt worden für dafür braucht man eine Sicherheitslücke und die hatten ja hier noch nicht mal Sicherheit.
Ja also es ist ja also ich kann ich kann mir gar nicht das ist ja noch nicht mal versucht,
wenn man einfach sagt okay auf der Sozialversicherungsnummer geben wir sofort diese Daten raus nicht nur man kann sich mit der einloggen seine man kriegt auch noch Daten zurück über diese Nutzer sehr total total absurd.
Ja es ist so diese mittelalterlichen Prozesse die da greifen dass wir irgendwie ein Bote eine schlechte Nachricht überbringt dass er dann auch gleich geköpft wird Song.
Ja wirklich.
Also Beine ein sehr peinlicher Umgang und man kann nur hoffen ich habe jetzt für die Berichterstattung darüber ein bisschen verfolgt.
Das nimmt den irgendwie auch bisher in der Berichterstattung keiner so wirklich ab dann wird also so ein bisschen auch die die Verrücktheit dir dieser Interpretation der Arbeiterkammer,
indem in der Berichterstattung im auch der Regel gewürdigt.
Die Rabenkrähe,
sich die Bestrafung des des Vogels der die schlechte Nachricht überbringt wird dann die wurde dann in die schwarze Farbe getaucht die Rabenkrähe ist dann sang Bus Krächzen und leiden,
Corvus corone corone.
Wer auch leiden musste.
Hat schon wieder.
Ja und zwar neu von uns regelmäßig empfohlene datenschutzorganisation von Max Schrems die sich ja darauf konzentriert.
Quasi Verstöße gegen die datenschutz-grundverordnung von großen Unternehmen vor Gericht zu bringen.
Und hat eben eine Beschwerde gegen Google eingereicht weil sie ihre Nutzer in in ihren Apps nicht ausreichend über,
über die Tracking und Datenerfassung die dort stattfindet informieren und deswegen auch keine valide Einwilligung für die Datenverarbeitung haben also eine quasi hier einen Verstoß gegen die,
datenschutzgrundverordnung vorliegt und da haben sie in Frankreich jetzt recht bekomme.
Und haben gesagt die Informationen die Google bereitstellt ist nicht einfach zugänglich für die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer,
außerdem ist diese Information,
nicht immer klar oder verständlich ja also was ihr da macht ihr ihr informiert die Leute nicht,
Ägypten die Leute die die Informationen nur widerwillig und versteckt sie irgendwo und die Informationen sind nicht so sinnvoll und einfach beschrieben wie man wie man sie beschreiben könnte,
außerdem und und deswegen ist der die die Zustimmung die den Nutzer euch geben nicht ausreichend informiert die die datenschutzgrundverordnung setze eine informierte Zustimmung zur Datenverarbeitung voraus.
Und wenn davon also sagt ihr müsst für jede spezifische Nutzung.
Die Einwilligung der Leute haben und die Leute müssen vorher erklärt bekommen haben wem sie da einwilligen dass es hier nicht der Fall.
Und deswegen ist dieser der gesammelte die gesammelte Zustimmung weder spezifisch noch.
Also für ist quasi ungültig Ja und deswegen kriegt er jetzt eine Strafe und zwar 50000000 Euro Strafzahlung.
Da ist dann auch mal die Portokasse leer.
Jana sagt jetzt neu bin in ihrer Bewertung ja das ist eine Rekordstrafe also noch nie hat ein Unternehmen eine so hohe Strafe zahlen müssen 50000000 Euro für Datenschutzverstöße aber,
theoretisch hätten des 3,7 Milliarden sein können weil das ja diese Prozent am Umsatz gibt also die Höchststrafe wäre.
3,7 Milliarden gewesen und da sagen Sie jetzt da ist es natürlich erst am unteren Ende und für Google natürlich nicht ein so großes Problem wie es hätte sein.
Also neu benennt dass er so das ist halt ne ne.
Von der rote Karte die sicher bekommen haben aber jetzt keine für Google noch zu verschmerzen wenn wichtiges Signal auch an andere Datenschutzbehörden das tatsächlich auch nennenswerte Strafen überhaupt ausgesprochen werden können wird ja häufig,
kritisiert dass eben die Datenschutz Strafen in der Regel so gering sind das,
dass die leicht ein zu Preisen sind google hat angekündigt dass sie sich dagegen wehren werden das heißt sie werden im Zweifelsfall ihr wie vor Gericht ziehen um um gegen diese Strafe.
Ging diese Strafe irgendwie sich,
die zu bekämpfen und sie im geweckt zu urteilen tja ich bin mal gespannt wie sich das weiterentwickelt an der Stelle empfiehlt außerdem noch dass sie einige,
Stellen offen haben und sie sich Verstärkung in ihrem Team wünschen durch eine leitende Juristin Software Entwicklerin oder eine juristische Praktikantin gibt also 3 Uhr stellen,
bewerbungsfrist bis 5. Februar verlängert das heißen. Bis morgen könnt ihr euch noch bei neu bewerben.
Ja so auch was schönes wo sitzen die denn jetzt eigentlich.
In Wien oder hätte ich jetzt gedacht das weiß ich gar nicht gucken wir mal schnell.
Denken tun wollen dich das auch aber wissen
ist gerade schwierig ich schau mal kurz nach Jahren European Centre for that alright
goldschlagstraße 11 40 Wien Events Wien eurer Mitte Lebensmittelpunkt schon ist oder sein sollte oder könnte.
Dann ist das vielleicht was für euch.
Ja sowieso bisschen Flexibilität davon ja wohl von der Praktikant hinten verlangen er ist aber jetzt nicht zu viel verlangt für so ein Praktikum bei umzuziehen.
Über.
Wir bleiben bei unseren Freunden in Österreich denn da gibt ja auch noch die Organisation epicenter works wo der Thomas
Lohninger die der Thomas Lohninger gegründet hat mehr oder weniger der ja auch bei uns regelmäßig als Podcaster zu hören ist.
Und epicenter works hat eine einen Report veröffentlicht zur Nettetal ität und zwar gibt es jetzt ungefähr seit zwei Jahren das Verbot von,
oder der der deine relativ weitreichende Regeln zur Netzneutralität die Verletzung der Netzneutralität größtenteils verbieten.
Aber leider einige Schlupflöcher lassen und genau die untersucht dieser Bericht von von Apps Center works nämlich da,
das was,
häufig eben noch gemacht wird in Europa sind sogenannte zero-rating Angebote also das wo bestimmte Teile der Internetnutzung anders behandelt werden.
Als das Haupt Volumen primär solche Scherze wie es streamon bei der Deutschen Telekom wo sie also sagen ja du hast uns so viel Datenvolumen aber
Spotify und Apple music und YouTube gehören irgendwie nicht dazu die kriegst du kostenlos obendrauf das wird nicht auf dein Datenvolumen angerechnet problematisch weil das natürlich,
bestimmte Anbieter bevorteilt gegenüber anderen nämlich die die da mitmachen werden natürlich,
lieber genutzt von den von den Telekom Nutzerin als andere Anbieter.
Deswegen ist es generell nicht wünschenswert dass so etwas
gibt und jetzt kommt dieser Report hat also eine hat alle zero-rating Angebote in Europa erhob hat er in jedem einzelnen europäischen Land bei allen Anbietern geschaut was haben die da was kosten diese Angebote und haben,
das einfach mal den kompletten kompletten europäischen Binnenmarkt erfasst und verglichen und kommt zu dem Ergebnis.
Dass sie berating die Preise für mobiles Datenvolumen teurer mach.
Und sagen also in den unterschiedlichen Ländern gibt es sehr unterschiedliche.
Herangehensweise zur Erzwingung der Netzneutralität einige erheben Strafen wir haben das ja hier auch in,
Deutschland gesehen dass die Bundesnetzagentur Versuch
dieses zero-rating Angebot der Deutschen Telekom irgendwie einzudämmen dafür sind sie aber im Zweifel sie die ganze Zeit dabei sich gegenseitig zu verklagen weil die Bundesnetzagentur Strafen erlässt die Deutsche Telekom dann,
diese Straßen zurückweisen will und dagegen klar dann natürlich die Mobilfunkanbieter sind,
nicht transparent darüber welche
Form von Eingriffe sie den Netzverkehr machen auch das müssten Sie nach der Netzwerk alität Verordnung tun müssten also sagen was genau wie ihre Eingriffe sind ab wann welche Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung undsoweiter sie da einführen.
Und entscheidend eben die.
Da wo sie berating gibt ist es Internet teurer also in der der der der Preis für Datenvolumen ist in den Ländern wo es das gibt zwei 2% über das Jahr gestiegen.
Und in den in den Märkten wo es kein zero-rated gibt ist der Preis für Daten um 8 Uhr % gesunken.
Jedes Jahr also es wird jedes ja Prozent billiger und da wo es im Rating gibt ihr dieses Jahr 2%.
Was heißt die Konsum Konsumenten denken dass sie mit dem zero-rating irgendwie etwas billiger bekommen weil er über die etwas kostenlos bekommen in in Wirklichkeit kriegen sie aber teurere Angebote.
Weil sie diesen begrenzten diesen eingeschränkten Zugriff auf das Netz halt dann teuer bezahlen und außer.
Funktioniert super.
Funktioniert super denn außerdem verletzen wir auch noch die Privatsphäre denn sie müssen ja Methoden haben um zu unterscheiden
was denn Uhrzeit gerade macht guckst du irgendwie ein YouTube-Video oder oder machst du irgendwas anderes das heißt Sie müssen quasi die Nutzung das Nutzungsverhalten erfassen.
Für diese Abrechnung und damit Ebenen auch Traffic Analysen machen die eben ja die Privatsphäre der Nutzer.
Berühren tja schön weil das der die erste ausführliche Erhebung ist ne ne
richtige Studie quasi wo alles erfasst wurde nach ich seit mal im weitesten Sinne eben wissenschaftlichen Methode neben Preiseffekte hier nachgewiesen wurden die denke ich mal.
Eindeutig zeigen dass es eben nicht im Interesse der Nutzerinnen und Nutzer ist wenn solche zero-rating.
Dinge angeboten werden.
Ja so siehts aus genau ist schlecht also könnt ihr auf jeden Fall euch auch mal durchlesen den Bericht oder Zusammenfassung auch bei seinen Kollegen von netzpolitik.org.
Ist sicherlich einiges drin zu finden für die politische Argumentation.
Schön ist vor allem noch einen ein letztes Argument was was in den Bericht angebracht wird die sagen die meisten Applikationen also die
die mag die Applikation die am meisten gesehene rated sind na damit in allen Ländern geschaut haben überall geguckt was wir gesehen rated haben von denen die Top 20 genommen,
also die die 20 am meisten zero-rated Applikation da sind nur drei von aus Europa und der Rest ist eben,
aus aus anderen Ländern das heißt die,
sie sagen das ist quasi für den für den europäischen digitalen Binnenmarkt von Nachteil dieses zero-rating Vorteile treffen größtenteils Unternehmen die nicht in Europa,
revidieren.
Was noch mal ein Argument eben sein könnte was auf EU-Ebene dann vielleicht doch interessant ist wenn die nämlich sagen wenn sie sehen
das ist gar nicht so geil für uns für unseren digitalen Binnenmarkt den wir versuchen,
zu errichten mit dem irgendwie was rocken wollen,
vielleicht schafft man es darüber zu gehört zu bekommen viel sollte natürlich sein dass wir alle zu vernünftigen Preisen.
Viel Internetvolumen haben und und ganz allein dafür darüber entscheiden können wie wir das nutzen wollen wie es in vielen anderen Ländern,
ja heute auch schon der Fall ist wo man ernstzunehmende Datenvolumina bekommen kann,
und sich nicht darum gekümmert wird und keine Vorschriften gemacht werden ja hier Google heute von 14 Uhr bis 18 Uhr kostenlos und.
Konkurrenz kokorin der Anbieter eben bezahlt werden.
Da
was dadurch klar wird ist dieses Netzneutralität Argument ist halt nicht nur ein Argument für Gleichbehandlung was ist eben auch ein Argument für einen offenen Markt in dem sich einfach,
die Preise auch für alle viel besser entwickeln als in einem kontrollierten schlecht kontrollieren.
Monopolisiert bei Monopoly.
Und dann haben wir noch Neuigkeiten aus der Welt des staatlichen hacking da gibt's einen Reuters Artikel über eine,
Frau die bis 2014 bei der NSA gearbeitet hat mit dem Namen Loris Streit und dann,
in der Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate eine in den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten.
Für ein Unternehmen gearbeitet hat das dafür die für die Regierung spioniert hat und sagte sie haben mehr oder weniger so eine.
IPhone hacking platform da gehabt wo sie eine Telefonnummer deine E-Mail-Adresse eingeben mussten auf die iMessage registriert ist,
und dann konnten sie quasi wenn Sie die da eingegeben haben wurde dieses Gerät dann automatisch gehackt was also,
darauf hindeutet dass die Schwachstelle inmessage war über die eine Infektion des Gerätes stattgefunden hat und sie hat dann da im Auftrag der der,
Regierung der Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate irgendwie hunderte.
Politische Gegner und so weiter infiltriert,
viele prominente Personen die jetzt irgendwie in der Politik da eine Rolle spielen und dann hatte sie aber und das finde ich immer sehr erstaunlich.
Bei Amerikanern ist diese diese ethische Schwelle die ist immer sehr sehr klar definiert denn was sie nicht tun ja was er was der der Amerikaner hat was er nicht macht,
oder wird was dir schlecht findet ist wenn dämlich.
Amerikaner ausspioniert werden also die hat halben Mittleren Osten über im Auftrag der Emirate infiziert und und ausspioniert aber als dann,
gesagt würde ich hier diese Person und es handelte sich um eine amerikanische Zielpersonen da war dann auf einmal die ethische Grenze.
Und dann hat sie gesagt ne jetzt mache ich hier jetzt mache ich Whistleblowing jetzt jetzt kündige ich hier das ist ja wohl völlig absolut abwegig was hier getan wird Amerikaner ausspionieren und.
Aber der da hinten.
Bekommen dahin und hat dann ihren Job gekündigt und hat jetzt eben,
ausgepackt FunFactory hat bei Booz Allen Hamilton diesen NSA Zulieferer damals auch Edward Snowden angestellt.
Die gute Lory Stroud hat aber wohl offenbar noch ein paar Jahre länger gebraucht um die.
An dem Punkt zu kommen wo sie Amerikaner ausspionieren musste und dann gesagt hat das machen wir nicht mehr weiter Raumstation amüsant finde ist tatsächlich war das auch für Snowden,
also der ausschlaggebende Punkt ne dass er sagte so gerne hier wenn ihr auch Daten von Amerikanern gesammelt hat ja relativ viel drüber gesprochen.
Und auch der wie heißt der Drake mit dem Laster mit Vornamen Thomas.
Ja das ist das so so der Knackpunkt ja da steht man hat auch mal so ein bisschen fassungslos davor so ja Amerikaner das hat mir ja auch ein Bier als ihre Vorträge auf den Kongressen Gehalt.
Genau wir hatten nämlich werten den den Thomas Drake glaube ich auch beim beim Kämpfer das glaube ich.
Nee ich habe auch in Hamburg auch schon auf dem Kongress.
Rhabarber,
sogar mehr mal oder ja oder in Hamburg genau und das ist die erzählt dies die die setzen sich dann ins Flugzeug fliegen nach Europa auf dem Kongress und halten allen Ernstes ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken ewigen Vortrag darüber wie dass man das ja wohl überhaupt nicht gegen das man auf dass man Amerikaner
ausspioniert ja und Erfinders also diese.
Merken überhaupt nicht sehr überhaupt nicht die die kognitive Dissonanz die da irgendwie gerade stattfindet soll das ist echt interessant ne.
Na das ist ja was was willst Du erwarten Polisport liegen schon World Series heißen Wasser also in den USA ist halt world ist halt wohl,
und das andere ist halt weiß ich nicht extra 3.
Das ist echt das ist echt geil also diese.
Die können sich schweren.
TÜV musste die haben ist wirklich bemerkenswert.
Ja das ist so ein andere auch ein Problem dieser Anglo sagst du wischen Sphäre.
Immerhin die Schwachstelle die ist dabei iMessage gab die ist offenbar irgendwie auch schon vor einigen Jahren von Apple behoben worden unklar bleibt welches woher hatten sie diese
Schatz auf der wird ihr wie beschrieben dass sie,
Schwachstelle die da ausgenutzt wurde in iMessage zur Infektion der Geräte eben auch gekauft haben ja also
genau das ja Schwachstellen die irgendwie halt unter der Hand gehandelt wurden auf einem Schwarzmarkt alles alles das schreckliche was man sich vorstellt hat dieses Unternehmen getan nämlich,
Schwachstellen auf diesen Geräten auf allen Geräten hingenommen.
Sogar dafür bezahlt dass sie die dass ihr das Wissen über diese Schwachstelle haben und andere nicht uns alle dem Risiko ausgesetzt diese Schwachstelle hatten ja nicht nur die Geräte die die angegriffen haben sondern alle.
Und dann das ganze natürlich hier in in sehr zweifelhaften politischen,
context inklusive irgendwie Fotos von Leuten in unvorteilhaften Positionen anfertigen damit man bisschen was in kompromat Köfferchen hat.
Alles völlig in Ordnung aber als ich dann wehe du machst das mit dem Amerikaner da kannst du nicht machen das geht ja wohl überhaupt nicht.
Irgendwo ist es ja auch mal Schluss gute Stichworte race.
Was ist jetzt auch mal.
Heute mal keine überlange Sendung.
Nee genau müsste auch mal üben kurze sendung zu machen wenn wenn wir schon irgendwie uns lange über App Apps Tore unterhalten.
Dann dann erkennt man es war nicht so viel los in der Welt und das ist ja dafür Wasser immer noch ausreichend schlecht alles insofern.
Da muss ich nicht mit guten Nachrichten belästigt.
Genau deswegen wie immer am Ende ein bisschen Dank für einige sehr spät nachgereicht und zwar danke in wilde ich gerne Dana,
Ricarda Steve Christoph Martin Jens und,
einer unbekannten Person die sich herzlich gerne kurz bei mir melden darf wenn das nicht beabsichtigt war dass sie anonym geblieben.
Ein Denkmal für die unbekannte Lehrerin.
Graf natürlich eine Lehrerin.
Super das war's Leute wir sehen uns und hören uns vorallem nächste Woche wieder.
Bis dahin gehabt.